qu'est-ce qui fait qu'une femme est
jolie c'est la maquillage quand les
femmes enlèvent leur maquillage elles ne
sont plus jolies elles sont jolies mais
pas trop j'ai vu des Africains qui
prennent des cheveux qui ne leur
appartienent pas et qui mettent ça sur
leurs cheveux pour augmenter qu'ils ont
les cheveux français alors quand il
passent dans les ru les garçons eu aussi
les suivent et puis disent que ce sont
des ce sont des filles françaises
pourquoi les européenes mettent-ell des
perruques à ton
avisêêtre belle et tu trouves qu'elles
sont belles non tu n'aimes pas voir ça
je n'aime pas voir ça timéon ça pour
faire la maline moi je vois le
maquillage c'est du gaspiage de l'argent
si c'est à moi m VI me dire de lui
donner l'argent pour qu'elle aille
défiser s cheveux je vais pas vouloir
mais si c'est elle même qui a son argent
ça c'est pas mon affaire moi j'aime bien
que ma femme se maquille si par exemple
ma femme est vilaine elle doit se
maquiller pour être belle